bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous alors que faut-il attendre selon
vous de ce conseil de défense
et finalement d'exécuter ce et est
contraint par cette vague au micro mais
apparemment laisse entendre que
peut-être les mesures restrictives que
l'on a annoncé depuis un certain nombre
de joueurs ne seront peut-être temps
rendu nous allons bien voir ce qui va
sortir cette fois c'est de défense qui
est sûr c'est que le conseil
scientifique est sur une position qui
est une position manifestement beaucoup
plus restrictive que les aujourd'hui le
pouvoir politique on a vu récemment le
procès de scientifiques s'était prononcé
plus que le 31
décembre soit sous couvre-feu et que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire
l'elysée et matignon ne se sont pas
résolus à cette solution lors qu'en
sera-t-il dans quelques heures nous le
verrons bien ce qui est quand même assez
sur ses pelures marivaux on limite une
stratégie c'est à dire qu'en fait la
stratégie qui a été celle qui a été
déployée d'ailleurs pas seulement en
france dans la plupart des pays mais du
tout vaccinal aujourd'hui tout le show a
ses limites parce que tout simplement là
où on espérait que le vaccin allait nous
permettre de tourner définitivement la
porte virus la porte de l'épidémie
d'apache de l'épidémie pardon on se rend
compte que je n'en ai pas tout à fait le
cas même si les formes graves sont pour
le moins en tout cas limités grâce à la
couverture vaccinale arnaud bdd si vous
nous parler du conseil de scientifiques
qui voudraient prendre lui des mesures
plus restrictives et nous on a
l'impression que le gouvernement joue la
prudence qu'il ne veut pas imposer des
mesures y être odieux qu'il fait preuve
d'une certaine retenue pourquoi selon
vous oui pour des raisons qui sont à mon
avis d'abord lié au fait que il anticipe
le risque d'une lassitude voire d'une
montée du mécontentement d'une partie de
l'opinion publique qui et même si malgré
les études d'opinion sur le montrer que
le public est assez favorable contre l
humanité et qui peut en tout cas aussi
être d'une certaine façon aujourd'hui de
plus en plus fatigués par les
contraintes qui pèsent sur sa vie de
tous les jours donc lhi d'anticiper
cette lassitude ce mécontentement il
fait le pari vraisemblablement c'est que
la vague du nouveau variant est une
vague qui certes est fortement
contagieuse ça je crois que c'est une
réalité à laquelle on est confronté mais
pas forcément plus dangereux de
formellement dangereuse que le delta
donc que si vrai ces deux éléments font
que
l'exécutif souhaite en tout cas vrai
sens ne pas durcir le dispositif bien
être enserrée les banques il faut pas
totalement
j'essaie que année dans un contexte pré
électoral et donc le contexte
pré-électoral fait que peut-être aussi
on considère que aujourd'hui durcir les
mesures c'est prendre le risque là aussi
de 10 ont radicalisé les plus opposant
aux mesures de contraintes sanitaires
voire de faire basculer une partie de
l'opinion dans une forme de
mécontentement sur le pass vaccinale qui
est donc au centre des débats olivier
ferrand a déclaré que que ce pass
vatinel est une forme déguisée
d'obligations vaccinale alors pourquoi
opter pour cette solution plutôt que
pour une vaccination tout simplement
obligatoire
oui c'est toute la difficulté finalement
de cette question depuis depuis le début
finalement il ya très peu de pays quand
on regarde la situation internationale
qui auront opté pour la solution de la
vaccination obligatoire parce que
clairement la vaccination obligatoire
est certainement d'abord très difficile
à mettre en pratique ça c'est un premier
élément deuxième élément c'est aussi une
façon pour l'exécutif de montrer qu'ils
ne peut pas être totalement toujours
dans la contrainte c'est à dire que
finalement il laisse le choix aux
individus de ce fait vous de ne pas se
faire vacciner mais évidemment ce qu'ils
feront le choix de ne pas se vacciner
verront leur vie sociale le en vie même
professionnel profondément entravé alors
y encourage on peut constater on pourra
considérer qu'il s'agit d'une stratégie
un tant soit peu hypocrite en la matière
la réalité c'est que quand même on peut
constater que le passé à lithaire dont
on peut discuter largement finalement de
la légitimité sur le plan des libertés
publiques a quand même entraîné la
vaccination d'une grande majorité de
français mais il reste aujourd'hui à ce
stade encore 5 millions de français qui
ne sont pas vaccinés autre point carré
vite il faut signaler le dernier contre
est important c'est que la vaccination
n'empêche pas la circulation du virus et
n'empêche pas le fait de pouvoir être
contaminé le pouvoir de pouvoir
contaminé de pouvoir contaminer les
autres et puis vous nous disiez il ya
quelques instants on est aussi à quatre
mois de la présidentielle et c'est
peut-être une stratégie de l'exécutif
oui alors évidemment encore une fois si
vous voulez le contexte pré-électoral
fait que l'exécutif est obligé
aujourd'hui de suivre au plus près
l'état de l'opinion si vous voulez de
manière beaucoup plus granulaire ils me
le faisaient certainement au moment où
noah pu démarrer l'épidémie c'est à dire
il ya maintenant presque deux ans donc
la relation à l'opinion publique était
un peu contre est aujourd'hui par ce
climat préélectoral clairement ce qu'on
constate c'est que la plupart des forces
politiques qu'à des forces politiques au
parlement sont pour l'instant sur une
ligne qui est une ligne de non
imposition
quant aux mesures vont vraisemblablement
être annoncés par l'exécutif compte
notamment sur le fait que l'on
transforme pas sali t on pas d'accident
il y aura quand même une question
importante qu il faudra regarder de près
est ce que le pass fax finale sera
assorti aussi pour avoir accès certain
nombre d'activités où un certain nombre
de lieux d'un test négatif
clairement si cette disposition était
prise par l'exécutif
ça en verrez quand même très mauvais
signal je pense très mauvais signal
notamment
à vis de l'efficacité de la vaccination
merci beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
haïti je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire merci à vous